learned the great lesson about that okay
i went to my great guy
you know okay
a few
weeks ago
it turned out it was my worst guy
my worst guy
so people change you know and i think we
have to accept that so please don't
believe the the best guy that you had
five years ago
he's the best and will be the best maybe
maybe he's mad because you left him
what maybe he's not the best guy because
you left him why the hell would he be
the best guy now
no i i didn't like so it wasn't
there's the last podcast you said you
left no that's my eggs oh it's not that
wasn't on my
i wish that was my best at least i would
have a
you know a good deja vu a recent good
deja vu no no no i wish that was my best
but no it wasn't what i think
okay
okay there's a couple exes here that i
think i'm maybe okay only three okay i
thought you said the nice one yeah that
was like the nicest one it was seven
year old i mean seven year uh
relationship that i had with him with
him i lived with him back in switzerland
for seven years that i have nothing to
say he's a great man
a great man that's not the one you went
back to no so why don't you she's
getting married if you were going back
to the nice guy why didn't you go back
to the actual no no no my great sex
let's say
he was the greatest sex okay the bad guy
so there's three guys only in my life so
you know what i mean like the
the great sex that uh that's the first
when i was 17 yeah 17 greatest sex in my
whole life you know like they turned
like a chicken liking on the grill
like a chicken on the grill i understand
i don't want that one
so he turned me like a chicken on the
grill you know i still have those
memories but once i went back there
a few weeks then i was like
no chicken in the grill
what the [ __ ]
oh like the sun it wasn't it was sex oh
my god it was me in a church with no
people there
wait we don't have time to do it no
people nothing it was like probably i
will see a mosquito let me let me let me
understand
i'm crying
so wait let me let me understand this
did you you slept with him in the church
or are you happy
no i'm not a sinner not like that i am a
senior sometimes everyone is come on
but i want it and yeah um so after the
last show you thought let's go back to
the the best guy
and i i was the worst guy no no no no no
no no but i thought you meant like the
nicest the best boyfriend but the nicest
boyfriend you meant the best sex yeah
like let's hit it but he was for nine
months oh it was kind of a relationship
no okay so so so you after the last
podcast you said let me hit him up and
then you slept with him again and it was
bad
no okay the last guy i was talking the
last postcard it was my recent ex okay
that's my third right the third okay the
second
two
you talked about this guy too oh yeah
the first one it was my greatest sex
okay i was 17 great sex
i i went back there
after 10 years after 10 years i was like
okay now i'm single you know i know i
don't want a life with him i don't want
nothing with him but you know it's good
to go in the chicken on the grill again
so why you can't raise your body count
i'm never getting a chicken
you know you know when you have a good
sex and you feel alive after 10 years
why turn
so i met him i even traveled oh my god
if i tell you the story girls how far
did you travel
luxembourg
where where but he played the flight
luxembourg yeah
but then i took a train and buzzed four
hours from the airport
it was mad
no chicken on the ground
not worth it not worth it not even if he
paid me a million i would go again
no no no his mental heal like in his
head
and um the sex was the worst like i
could count mosquitoes i could i could
be like on my head okay today's monday
uh-huh what time is it okay what did i
do today okay i probably cooked you know
like when you have good sex you don't
think about that you're in the moment
right you're like there but when you
have bad sex you think oh my god i have
to pay my bills i have to clean the
house i have lunch to do oh my god
tomorrow i have school so you're never
going through your daily tasks during
your like writing and just thinking
about okay [ __ ] is going on then why did
i came here and i was about to stay four
days and the next day i just left i was
like move
run
run
do you not see how like it proves the
point that like
the first time or i don't know if it was
the first time but the time you had sex
with your best
to the time that you recently had sex
with him
you you having multiple like partners
within that time has
now upped your experience yes so i
learned a great lesson and then now
you're in that situation where like
what was once your best moment has kind
of been ruined because you now know so
much more yeah so if you married the
first guy
the memory of the greatest sex that i
had with him is not it's not deleted and
will never be
but then you're going into you're going
into different relationships having that
image in your head these guys aren't and
that's the mistake girls ladies don't do
that yes
because that's a trap that's a big trap
don't do it you know because we compare
and that's the thing you were saying
before like we compare like the like the
guy that we had now that we have now to
the last one that we had and that's bad
girls because people change and
look at me after 10 years i went back
worse sex
don't do it like don't
don't think like the the grass is
greener in the other side never
never i'm gonna tell you and that's the
problem in this generation right now
with instagram and all that people get
attempted about photos and naked girls
and naked guys and they think oh that's
you know that's better or that's hotter
and then there's a lot of cheating
because we think always the green is the
green in the other side is is
the grass is green the grass is greener
on the other side so please girls don't
do that to yourselves you're gonna
traumatize yourself i did already i did
for all girls you see i sacrificed
myself to tell you girls no don't do it
you know really that was not the message
i was hoping you got out of this context
i i thought you were gonna maybe try to
rekindle with the ex that was like nice
to you
i know he's about to get married and
even though if he was single i wouldn't
because
um i really broke up with him you like
the narcissist it's a little bit the
[ __ ] no
i think you do that's why you keep going
back to no because the first guy you see
10 years ago he was a great guy he's
from portugal he was like neighbors with
my family like
and
he's been living with his mom so he's
been well raised but since he moved out
i think he kind of fall apart with this
how you say values her values i think he
kind of forgot those values
and i just felt completely
um lost with him like i felt somehow
i was not with a guy that i met 10 years
ago
i thought he was a different person the
way he act the way he talked
and no no i thought he was a great
person back then and he was he was
um but now
he's chicken
yeah yeah
so but the point the point is like
sleeping with multiple people does
impact your ability to pair bond yeah i
didn't sleep with much people why no but
it doesn't i didn't say i know i'm not
that i didn't say how many i said more
than one
oh okay yeah like yeah because even even
when you no no i'm not
i'm not making a judgment on what is a
lot that's not my point okay is the more
people that you sleep with the harder
it's going to be for a guy to get
married to you
and that's not a fun truth i don't think
that because i think as women like we're
forced to make decisions a lot sooner
than men and you're given a lot of
attention from a young age
especially if you're like a very pretty
girl like at like 15 you have guys
hitting on you all the time i think
girls have to make decisions quick yes
but i i think it's dishonest to say
there's no consequences to like sleeping
with multiple people because there are
and at least as women like we can have
this conversation and like be honest to
the next generation of women
definitely because yeah because that's
that's my problem is a lot of feminism
it
it promotes do what you want with your
body
but in a way that's almost encouraging
girls to be to be [ __ ] honestly it's
not like it's not you know like when
you're having a a tip march what what
the hell else are you supposed to call
that like like the patriarchy disguising
itself is feminism like if you're using
feminist terms
because it's like
you know if there's men out there that
like want to have sex with girls like
what best way to like get them to have
sex with them then tell them like it's
cool like you know what i mean like it's
feminist to like be sleeping around with
people you know what i mean i feel like
or very sexy
yeah it's like more in favor of men than
it is on women because then it also
weakens you as a woman you know as i
said as we said before like it can um
it can damage you can uh affect your
self-worth whether you want to accept it
or or not and then you're going to also
like lower your standards you know and
and just and go for anything and in
regards to what we're saying earlier i
feel like not only do we compare but we
also romanticize the past so it's not
that that other person was necessarily
better but when you're in a situation in
the present you're very aware of the
positive and the negative and sometimes
more than negative but when you look
back on the past we have
um we're we're biased towards the
positives you know we that's why we
always say like the good old days you
know the past was always better because
not because it actually was but because
we tend to forget the negative things
faster than we than we do the the good
stuff mm-hmm so
have any of you ever gone um back to an
x and forgot how toxic it was